all right so valve recently dropped
maybe one of the worst updates in recent
memory for cs go
they rolled out trusted mode this weird
anti-cheat system
that's causing a lot of problems for
some of cs go's player base
some people are experiencing dropped
frame rates a giant impact to
matchmaking
hell some people can't even start the
game right now
so i talked to a security expert about
whether this thing is actually effective
at stopping hackers
whether or not it's just a glorified pr
move and why so many people are having
problems in the first
place so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so the score esports is
streaming over at twitch.tv
the score esports and we have a ton of
streams happening throughout the week
chess on tuesdays our talk show clouded
on wednesdays
and behind the desk on thursdays so if
you haven't already go ahead and give
the channel a follow
so you know exactly when we go live okay
now back to the story back in june valve
launched its anti-cheat system
thing trusted mode into beta before
fully patching it into cs go on july
8th and almost immediately there were
problems people complained to frame rate
drops the fact that it could potentially
screw with their truss score
which has a big impact on your
matchmaking experience or hell just
being unable to run the game at all and
on july 8th
trusted mode moved from an opt-in beta
that players could choose to participate
in
to a fully patched piece of csgo's
architecture
basically something that now everyone
has to deal with
and if you've ever read valve patch
notes for cs go you know they're not the
most descriptive it's usually just a
bunch of bullet points explaining what's
new
with the game and the original patch
notes for trusted mode are no different
they announce the feature and then throw
specifics at you
like quote by default players will
launch csgo in trusted mode which will
block third-party files from interacting
with the game
end quote but then it doesn't explain
what that means so naturally the
combination of all these problems made
people ask
uh valve what the [ __ ] is this thing so
valve quickly released a longer blog
post explaining what trusted mode is
but not before the problems started and
a lot of the problems we're about to get
into
existed in the beta and were actually
carried over into the fully patched
version of trusted mode and to properly
understand what trusted mode is and why
it's causing problems i spoke with
gamerduck who has a background in cyber
security and runs something called the
overwatch
police department which is a discord
server where you can report cheaters in
different fps games
and he'll do his best to get them banned
we've spoken to him a bunch in the past
for cheating centric don't at me
episodes so i think what they were
trying to do
is stop a lot of the pasting that's
going on in cs go
cs go is actually like if if you
wanted to create sheets and you asked
one of the cheat developers
hey i want to create sheets i want to
learn how you did it they will tell you
do it in csgo because
in cs go it's actually really easy to
create sheets there's a lot of tools out
there
basically he says what trusted mode is
trying to do is also its biggest
problem namely stopping third party
software from communicating with cs go
so if you have obs discord or nvidia
freestyle graphics filters open while
trying to run cs go
you'll be met with a message that tells
you to close any third-party software
and to relaunch csgo in trusted mode
you literally can't run the game with
something as simple as spotify open in
the background here's a quote from the
longer blog post dedicated to trusted
mode
quote some applications interact with
csgo by injecting directly
into the game process this method is
used by common applications as well as
cheats
we can vastly improve cheat prevention
by restricting injections
altogether as opposed to determining
whether an injection is a cheat or not
end quote gamerdoc says that valve is
essentially saying that because
hackers are hiding cheating software
within normal
and usually safe third-party software
valve's just gonna ban
everything from trying to connect to cs
go it's not unusual because the reason
why
it's blocked it's because uh cheaters
are using really using these uh
vulnerable
softwares like they have some they have
vulnerable
locations in the software so obs for
instance you're able to hook onto obs
with a driver or whatever and be able to
cheat
through obs or you could cheat through
nvidia stuff
or you could cheat through uh discord's
overlay
that's the reason why they're blocking
it it's because it's not
the fault of the anti-sheet team it's
the fault of the company
not removing these vulnerable things now
trusted mode doesn't specifically tell
you
what third-party software is potentially
raising red flags
so unless you're literally only running
cs go
have fun trying to figure out what
applications you need to close
gamerduck described trusted mode as a
glorified pr
move in response to vanguard which is
riot games's
intrusive anti-cheat system that they
rolled out with the release of valerian
he said that vanguard operates at the
kernel level of your computer's
architecture
which basically means it's a level of
your computer software that the general
gamer
rarely if ever has to deal with and
according to gamerdoc it's here at the
kernel level where you'll find the most
sophisticated and hardest to spot
cheating software
and again according to him cs go's
trusted mode doesn't work on this level
at all
instead operating on a more surface
level basis
which he's told us in the past does
almost nothing to stop
hacking or cheating software from
getting into your computer and listen
these days
intrusive anti-cheat systems are out
there faceit has one
vanguard is one it's not like valve
doesn't know they have to go deeper into
your computer's architecture
to actually stop cheating which is why
gamerdoc speculates that trusted mode is
more of a glorified
pr move than actually a piece of
software that's going to keep people
safe
the best solution like in any like
organization like that has an anti-cheat
i think kernel
is like the best solution to combat the
cheaters
at least from my perspective like seeing
vanguard
completely annihilating every single
copy paster
on just like private sheets even like as
you can see
like the two private two pro players who
got
uh banned for cheating and all that kind
of stuff like they are really
aggressive with their anti-cheat and
it's really working
he also told me that within an hour of
trusted mode going live
hackers had found a way around it he
even sent me screenshots and links to
forums where hackers and cheaters were
openly talking about
how simple this system was to hack so
yeah trusted mode hasn't seemed to have
stopped people from cheating and
it just seems to have made things worse
for people who just want to play
competitive
on top of the third party software issue
players have complained about frame rate
drops when doing something as simple
as moving your mouse across the screen
and according to both
valve and gamerdoc this is a side effect
of trusted mode and the anti-third-party
software stance that valve is taking
but it's also a problem that they're
actively looking to fix
quote sometimes applications attempt to
inject during low-level windows mouse
events which results in noticeable
performance degradation
when the mouse is moved we are
internally testing a mechanism that has
virtually zero overhead
even from the most zealous of injecting
software once this new approach
ships players should no longer notice a
performance impact from running in
trusted mode
even when moving the mouse end quote
after the cs go community complained
that this thing was a giant pain in the
ass
valved pushed out two new patches the
latest of which went live on july 23rd
in it they talk about fixing performance
issues related to trusted mode
and they provided a temporary fix to
allow third-party software
to communicate with cs go quote a new
compatibility launch
option dash allow third-party software
is provided to allow third-party
software to access the cs go
game process so basically if you punch
that line of code into your steam
preferences
prior to launching cs go apparently
third-party software now works with the
game
but my question is doesn't this defeat
the whole point
if hackers are using third-party
software to cheat in cs go
why would you let people turn off the
option that apparently stops that
now valve has given players the option
to completely turn off trusted mode
and play in the old version of cs go but
there's a catch
quote if you would like to play while
using third party software that
interacts with cs go
launch with the dash untrusted launch
option
note that in this case your trust score
may be negatively affected
end quote that last sentence stands out
to me your trust score
may be negatively affected remember your
trust score is one of the ways valve
figures out who to cue you with in
matchmaking
so if you play with trust mode turned
off that score could be negatively
impacted even if you've done
nothing wrong okay but where does all of
this leave us
well the good news is is that valve is
working on fixes which they noted in
their july 23
patch note blog post and while this
definitely won't fix cs go's cheating
problem
gamerdoc does think that this trusted
mode is a part of valve's larger
long-term plan to fight back against it
i think personally i think it was just a
marketing thing it was just to calm down
some of the players because of
the huge influx of cheaters and it's and
this influx of cheaters is not going to
stop believing like it's going to
increase
and increase unless something major
happens
my trust score is dog [ __ ] valve doesn't
make the criteria public
but you know if you if he is so obvious
it is so obvious if you run down the
list right colin you're right it's
it's tking team killing it's leaving
matches mid match
it's being a toxic piece of [ __ ] in chat
it's
uh it's just being a piece of [ __ ] and
honestly
i've done every single one of those
things multiple [ __ ] times
i'm a pretty trustworthy human being
just not when it comes to playing video
games